la question quand je teste un produit
comme celui-là comme la samsung galaxy
tab est ce cette ff le pur fan edition
c'est de savoir si je pourrai vous
recommander ce produit comme je le
recommanderais à n'importe quel ami ben
oui on est amis vous êtes mes amis est
ce que je pourrais vous recommander ce
produit est ce que ce produit est
suffisamment intéressant et vous savez
qu'on tombe à comparer des produits
quand on s poser cette question et bien
il faut se poser la question du marché
de la concurrence des usages enfin il ya
beaucoup de variables à bien prendre en
considération et c'est toutes les
questions je me suis posée depuis que
j'ai ce produit dans les meubles depuis
que je m'amuse avec samsung fait deux
très bons produits il y en a pour tous
les budgets je vous parle beaucoup de
smartphones de samsung et je vous parle
aussi de temps en temps de tablettes
alors cette tablette je voulais déjà
présenté quand elle a été présentée vous
ai déjà dit plein de choses d'ailleurs
si vous n'avez pas vu je vous invite à
venir voir cette vidéo je vais pas dire
la même chose ici je vais pas vous ré
expliquer la fiche technique c'est pas
l'idée de cette vidéo là donc si vous
connaissez pas la vidéo d'avant je vous
invite à bien la voir jouer ailier en
bas d'un description quelque part par an
ici maintenant la question c'est est-ce
que je pourrais vous recommander ce
produit là compte tenu des autres
tablettes qui existent samsung galaxy
tab est 7 samsung galaxy tab est sais
plus
[Musique]
samsung samsung samsung samsung samsung
tous mpla samsung samsung toussait
beaucoup plaire avec un projet comme
celui là alors on va y aller directement
va se dire catch up la reconnaissance du
visage tu reconnais pas mon visage
pourquoi je ne sais pas à ce que je
parle voilà il vous pouvez venir le
déverrouiller grâce à votre visage
pratique bon et on connaît ça c'est un
très très grand classique ce que je vais
aimer sur cette tablette est ce grand
écran très grand écran très confortable
à venir visionner on a un ratio de 19
10e ça je vous ai déjà dit dans la vidéo
de présentation donc je vais pas vous le
redire ici ce que j'aime bien ici un
regard des coûts calme toi c'est ce
grand écran comme je le disais ça c'est
du 18 4 pouces exactement la même taille
d'écran qu'on retrouve sur la samsung
galaxy tab s est plus les noms
deviennent très très compliqué au niveau
toutes les références du tout les
produits samsung galaxy tab est c'est
plus c'est la même taille d'écran de
quoi bien vraiment se positionner entre
7 samsung galaxy tab et c'est plus et 7
samsung galaxy tab est 7ème feu on va
venir les met face à face alors les prix
sont pas les mêmes et je vous dis
directement regard des frais tout est
écrit ici
la samsung galaxy tab s est plus à une
version 5 g il ya une version wifi alors
moi je vous parlerai de la version wifi
pour la samsung galaxy tab est c'est
plus que le modèle le plus haut de gamme
celle là elle est en 5 g pour l'instant
il n'existe qu'en 5 g mais si vous avez
un smartphone et je pense que vous avez
à 64,88 tout le monde à smartphone est
bien fait un partage de connexion avec
vos smartphones et vous aurez de la 5g
grâce à votre partage de collection donc
j'ai pas bien à comparer par rapport à
la samsung galaxy tab est c'est + 5 g
mais par rapport à la version wifi
qu'est moins cher alors sur la version
samsung galaxy tab et c'est + wifi
suivait ça fait beaucoup de références
et bien vous avez une version en 256 go
de stockage t'écoute 929 euros bah oui
parce qu'à une petite remise de 100
euros en ce moment et sur la version 128
go de stockage c'est vraiment ça la cnav
bien intéressé vous la touchez à 8 149
euros avec ses fameuses 100 euros de
remise des lui tandis que sur ce modèle
là sur la version 128 go de stockage
vous êtes à 719 euros c'est à dire d'un
côté vous avez une tablette à plus haut
de gamme qui à 849 euros contre celle là
qui est à 719 euros ça veut dire que
j'ai 120 euros d'écart alors 120 euros
d'écart ça reste quand même beaucoup
d'argent mais sur des sommes réservées
sur dix au budget parce qu'on est quand
même sur le haut du panier on se pose la
question est ce que je vais mettre 120
euros de plus pour la différence et vous
allez quand la différence allait quand
même relativement significative voire
même carrément très significative c'est
vrai quand on la regarde comme ça
ressemble vraiment beaucoup à la samsung
tab s est plus vous avez ce très grand
écran de 2,4 pouces la différence va se
faire au niveau la technologie ici vous
n'avez pas de super amoled vous êtes
sûre du lcd vous êtes sûre du tft sur la
samsung galaxy tab s est pas le modèle
plus mais l'asn vous êtes également sur
du lcd vous êtes sûre du lt ps alors cdu
11 pouces c'est plus petit donc c'est
pour ça que je vais pas la comparer ici
à ce modèle là mais là là par contre
voyez la techno d'écran même si elle
fait le taff sera loin bonne moins
intéressante vous n'êtes pas sûrs du
super amoled vous n'êtes pas sûr de
l'oled ce qui veut donc dire qu'on va
pas voir les contraste infini on ira
moins loin au niveau des couleurs qui
est déjà il ya une vraie différence la
suivante différence vous à venir la
retrouver regarder on vient voir ici
dans les paramètres c'est le taux de
rafraîchissement ici vous êtes
uniquement sur du 60 m vous n'avez pas
ici ni de 90 art ni de 120 hertz tandis
que soit le modèle plus on est sur du
sang manière dont vous voyez pour 120
euros d'écart déjà la différence avec
vraiment là et c'est vraiment vraiment
important dans ses premiers points le
deuxième point ça se jouer au niveau des
hauts parleurs parce qu'ici vous avez
des hauts parleurs stéréo premier haut
parleurs qui situe ici de ce côté-là et
2e haut-parleurs qui se situe ici de ce
côté là une fois de plus j'ai vraiment
composé ces deux produits pour essayer
de se situer par rapport aux tarifs le
tarif c'est toujours ce qui va nous
emmener sur un produit ou sur un autre
parce que à budget équivalent on irait
sur le produit le plus haut de gamme
celui qui en fait le plus celui qu'elle
puisse définition et une fois de plus à
120 euros d'écart voyez la question se
pose vraiment alors les haut parleurs
stéréo ils font leur taf spatialisation
on a un son qui devrait m'en de bonne
qualité mais une fois de plus pour un
delta de 120 euros est ce que j'irai sur
un produit ou j'ai quatre haut parleurs
ou est-ce que j'irai sur de par leur
j'irai très clairement sur l es4 parle
un bon malgré tout le boulot est
vraiment bien fait ici maintenant
l'autre question qui est extrêmement
important de voir peut-être la plus
importante c'est la question de la
performance ici je suis chez qualcomm
j'ai ici le snapdragon 750 g pour gaming
c'est important dont je vous ai déjà
parlé sur des smartphones qui marche
très bien qui fera tourner avec 80 à 90%
des jeux du ps store sans aucun problème
donc pour tous vos usages pour de la
productivité que soit pour du gaming ce
soir pour de la bureautique soit pour
des films des séries sans aucun problème
vous avez de quoi faire ici on n'est pas
trop sur les âges photo on a une seule
petite caméra ici c'est une caméra de 8
mégapixels
on va passer très rapidement ce qu'on va
pas venir utiliser sa tablette pour
faire des photos pour ça une fois de
plus vous avez des smartphones par
contre la performance c'est extrêmement
important sur la samsung galaxy tab s
est plus vous avez un snapdragon
865 plus qui est pas le plus performant
actuellement sur le marché amm est un
des plus performants du marché c'est la
série 8 de qualcomm c'est la série la
plus haut de gamme là on est sur une
série 7 qui est dans le milieu de gamme
qui ira très bien mais voyez une fois de
plus on garde ce delta 220 euros donc
avec une petite différence de 120 euros
est-ce que je vais partir sur ce modèle
là où sur l'autre à je crois que la
réponse commence un petit peu se dessine
et peint qui est super important mais
qui pend coup il n'est pas que de ce
produit là c'est la batterie vous avez
une grosse batterie de 10090
milliampères ok ça me va bien on
m'annonce que je peux avoir de la
recharge rapide jusqu'à 45 watts mais
pourquoi samsung pourquoi avec un
produit qui coûte plus de 700 euros me
met un bloc de charge de 15 mois ça
c'est un petit peu ras et ça je trouve
ça vraiment dommage parce que ça veut
dire que recharger une batterie de 10
milles 90 millions perreur marc bloch de
charge de 15 watts mais il faut s'armer
de patience alors on est sur une
tablette on n'est pas sur un smartphone
sur un smartphone ont dit ok je vais
leur charge et rapidement je le branche
ans l'une des meilleures parties là si
vous le branchez une des meilleures vous
l'avez pas changé clairement il faut
s'armer de patience on compass a ici en
minute non content ça en heure après
dans tous les cas je suis vraiment fan
de onu a eu chaud ça vraiment super bien
au niveau de l'expérience logiciel
samsung c'est une des meilleures
expériences avec menus à 13.1 basé sur
l'android 11 ça marche bien c'est
pratique c'est vraiment cool je sais pas
si vous connaissez je vous ai déjà
présenté quand je vous parle des
smartphones vous avez votre tiroir
d'applications vous avez accès à vos
paramètres très rapidement parfois nus a
ici c'est une super expérience donc quel
que soit le produit que vous allez
prendre 2 500 euros niveau des tablettes
au niveau des smartphones vous ne serez
absolument pas déçu ici il ya un autre
point qui est hyper important c'est ça
c'est le spd d'alors le splc un d'époque
est extrêmement important extrêmement
intéressant et si la grosse différence
que vous allez avoir avec la table et
cèdent plus et qui si l'espagnol n'est
pas connecté donc ici pas de bluetooth r
pas de connexion entre votre respect et
votre tablette ça non ça n'existe pas ça
ne fonctionne pas ça peut paraître un
peu dommage une fois de plus avec un
delta de prix de 120 euros alors
regardez il ya un truc qui est
intéressant est que j'ai vu ici là ça
situe juste ici lorsque vous prenez
votre tablette à regarder venez voir ça
c'est un truc très design fait puisque
nous fait samsung ils nous disent
regardez vous venez poser votre espèce
au dos vers votre caméra alors moi je
veux bien je prends ma tablette je viens
la positionner comme ça il trouve la
position il vient cimenter mais pour
autant en termes d' usage est ce que je
vais trouver ça bien de la voir comme ça
si je le glisse dans un sac et 20 qu'est
ce qui va se passer à ça va sauter
lorsque je me balade avec est-ce que je
suis sûr qu'ils ne risquent pas de
tomber parce que c'est le bon endroit je
ne suis pas persuadé alors a contrario
et je peux venir le positionner sur le
dessus là ça me paraît mieux au moins si
jamais glisse ben je le vois je suis
tout de suite informé donc ça ne
paraîtra beaucoup plus cohérent alors
moi seul espen je les aime bien il me
plaît bien je tient bien en main ça
c'est vraiment pratique pour venir les
griffonné dessiner faire plein de renard
et bien ça me conviendra parfaitement
bien pouvait venir à créer des notes
affichées les notes sélection
intelligente des captures bref c'est
tout ce qu'on peut faire avec un espen
donc ici je vais pas bien vous apprendre
grand chose si vous connaissez déjà
l'idée du spn donc ça marche bien
regarder je fais je fais des oeuvres
d'art et moi pablo picasso on peut venir
dessiner facilement peut venir griffonné
sur ce que vous voulez comme vous voulez
même le bruit de votre mine dessus mais
une fois de plus le vrai problème qui
est soulevé ici c'est pas le s pen sait
pas est ce que ce respect n'est
intéressant oui ils les traits clamant
la vraie question que je devais venir
soulever ici c est ce que je veux en
espagne connectés ou pas et est ce que
ces 120 euros de delta sont intéressants
ou pas l'esp elle est très bien j'aime
beaucoup je peux le mettre à l'oreille
j'ai l'air d'un mec hyper créatif ça me
va bien et pour travailler c'est un
super produit en plus de ça il ya un
truc qui est vraiment intéressant je
voulais pas montrer avec vous et des
petites connectique qui sont regardés la
situer juste en dessous vous pouvez
venir utiliser un clavier pour venir
transformer votre tablette un petit
ordinateur alors ça ressemblera
d'ordinateur on peut l'utiliser pour de
la bureautique politisés pour venir
taper pour autant il ne deviendra pas un
ordinateur vous pourrez faire de la
bureautique sans problème et même
pouvoir travailler à distance très
facilement vous avez trois micros dessus
ça fonctionne bien donc pour venir
échanger bon ok d'une caméra de 5
mégapixels à l'avant c'est pas la
meilleure caméra du monde mais pour la
collaboration professionnelle ou pour me
dire par année avec sa famille qui est
un petit peu loin sans aucun problème
serra parfaitement bien donc voyez ici
j'ai une super tablette qui est signée
samsung super finition des l'écran belle
proposition l'audio haute qualité j'ai
de la performance j'ai une grosse
batterie j'ai une belle autonomie dans
un peu plus de dix heures donc la pluie
j'ai rien à lui reprocher alors si
quelques petits points par ci par là au
niveau de la recharge une fois de plus
faux ça un peu dommage que quelques
petits points mais la vraie question qui
vient se poser ici c'est la politique
tarifaire par rapport au modèle le plus
haut de gamme que vous avez alors il est
évident que si vous allez sur le plus
haut de gamme du plus haut de gamme avec
la grosse config en 256 go de stockage
et sur la version 5 g il ya un delta et
vous n'allez pas y aller mais et c'est
vraiment intéressant si vous allez sur
la plus petite configuration comme je
vous le disais sur le 128 giga de
stockage c'est ici vous avez le sens
l'étudiant de stockage c'est la même
chose donc 128 go de stockage le wifi
est un partage de connexion et vos
smartphones et bien vous arriver grâce à
la réduction que vous avez aujourd'hui
sur le site de samsung d'ailleurs je
vous mets les liens en bas par la
description et bien vous arrivez un
delta de 120 euros donc vous touchez ce
produit là là 719 euros tandis que
l'autre vous touchez à 849 euros alors
moi je me dis toujours que 120 euros ça
reste beaucoup d'argent mais si je veux
m 719 euros dans un produit est ce que
je fais pas grimper un peu jusqu'à 8 149
euros pour être sûr d'avoir ce qui se
fait de mieux la question savoir s'il
faut acheter ce produit je dirais que si
vous voulez une très belle tablette très
belle finition de samsung pour de la
créativité si vous êtes un créatif
plutôt amateur on va pas se parler ici
de professionnels n'est plus d'amateurs
qui est griffonné keim la prise de notes
qu'elle travaillait avec un stylet qui
veut une tablette qui fonctionne bien si
vous voulez profiter d'une bonne
expérience au niveau du visionnage de
films séries si vous voulez pouvoir
jouer à des jeux sans aucun problème et
sans aucun ralentissement et bien si
vous avez une très très jolie tablette
même pour la collaboration
professionnelle bref c'est un très très
très joli produit je pense que pour
aller plus loin au niveau l'expérience
il faut lui rajouter le clavier qui
vendu en option et qui permettra
d'emmener un petit peu plus loin
l'expérience comme on peut le faire avec
un ipad procès vraiment l'équivalent des
produits ici mais pour autant si j'ai un
delta de 120 euros je ne vais pas sur ce
produit et je vais sur la samsung galaxy
tab s est plus donc tout va dépendre du
tarif auquel tout ce produit et si ce
produit il arrive sur le marché demain
en version wi fi et pas 5 g les tarifs
seront plus bas auquel cas il fera
beaucoup plus facilement de l'oeil parce
que vous avez de tarifs vous avez les
versions 128 go de stockage celle que
j'ai là 719 euros mais vous avez
également une version 4 gigas de ram 64
giga de stockage à 669 euros et dont les
salaires sont cinq gîtes donc si j'ai
pas une version 5 gemecs génération wifi
je serai en dessous des 600 euros
probablement à 550 euros probablement
jeudi probablement aurait vraiment dans
l'hypothétique si toutefois ce produit
arrive et auquel cas ça deviendra
vraiment intéressant j'espère en tout
cas j'aurais pu vous aider ce produit là
il est super mais lot l'est encore plus
à 120 euros d'écart pour moi le choix
c'est érigeant le plus haut de gamme à
vous de dire vous ce que vous en pensez
vous iriez vers lequel samsung galaxy
tab est cette f1 samsung galaxy tab est
c'est tout alors pourquoi pas la samsung
galaxy tab est certes plus et si oui à
quel tarif est ce que vous pourriez
succombé mark et moi ça n'a évidemment
pas aux commentateurs ont très vite pour
continuer à parler de teck parler de
produits par les symptômes pareil plein
de choses et ça c'est chouette les
bisous d'amour prenez soin de vous et
belle et tais toi